Gavin de Becker says his mission to find
out who leaked Jeff Bezos is private
information to the National Enquirer led
him to the Saudi government in The Daily
Beast the Amazon CEO security chief said
an investigation which included
interviews with spyware experts and
people with close ties to the Crown
Prince found with high confidence that
the Saudis had access to bezos's phone
and gained private information we're
going to push through this
in February Bezos accused the National
Enquirer as publisher ami of
blackmailing him by threatening to
publish lewd photos of him and his
alleged mistress former TV host Lauren
Sanchez ami has repeatedly said
Sanchez's brother Michael leaked all the
material and photos but he has denied
being the sole source still debecker
alleges ami may have already been
looking into the affair and approached
Michael Sanchez for proof debecker
claims that the Saudi government has
been intent on harming Bezos since last
October when his newspaper The
Washington Post began its relentless
coverage of Saudi journalist Jamal
khashoggi 'he's murder he wrote that it
is unclear to what degree if any ami was
aware of the details of the hack in a
statement ami called the claims false
and unsubstantiated the company added
there was no involvement by any other
third party whatsoever for CBS this
morning Jamie yuccas Los Angeles